as they'll send will crow to the mound
he is looking for his first major league
win the rookie right-hander will go for
the box bobby bradley is coming up
3-2 to bradley swinging a chop up first
base crow has it he'll flip it on to
moran covering for the out
three infield ground outs
nice start for will crow and now the
pirates coming to bat in the last of the
first no score and cal quantrill will be
on the mound for the tribe
his record this year owen two
three elevens is era here's moran the
payoff
a swing and a miss so cuantro wins it
with a strikeout of moran and 18 pitch
inning but cal cuantro keeps the pirates
off the board we have no score going to
the second here's harold ramirez
a 267 batting mark three homers 16 rbis
and the 2-1
swung on hit high and deep to left gamel
going back on the track at the wall it
is gone
harold ramirez with home run number four
you can hear the indians contingent
making their presence felt here in
pittsburgh
one nothing try
and now crow
to face bradley zimmer
here comes the payoff and right in there
strike three call
fastball at 96.
crow gets his first strikeout of the day
cleveland gets on the board on the home
run by ramirez the indians
with a one-nothing lead
and gregory polanco who hit a bomb last
night will lead off the pirates second
he's hitting fifth
left-handed batter in right field tribe
leading one-nothing polanco leading off
bottom of the second
the set by cuantra land the pitch and he
got him swinging
good slider
down maybe out of the zone polancos out
number one strikeout victim number two
the indians with a one-nothing lead and
we go to the third inning and leading it
off for the tribe is the number eight
hitter catcher renee rivera against the
right-hander will crow
into the wind and the 1-1
swung on hit high hit deep to left down
the line it goes gone
renee rivera with his first home run as
a cleveland indian
a towering blast down the left field
line
and that'll put the indians on top of
this one by a score of two to nothing
on a couple of solo home runs by the try
the pirates have runners at first and
third two down in the third
the indians on top
two to nothing and a dangerous
three-hole hitter at the plate center
fielder brian reynolds
single to right center on an o2 pitch
his first time up his hit the only one
the pirates have in three innings
with a 3-1 count on reynolds runners at
the corners two down two-nothing tribe
the pitch and it's swung on and a fly
ball weakly hit to left rosario with the
catch and cointreau somehow gets out of
it
three in the books
taiwan
playing third base
jose ramirez day to day
there's the o2
swinging and a miss
and chang is down on strikes two gone
bradley zimmer coming up 3-2 grounded to
first off of moran's glove onto second
and
both uh
moran and frazier bobble it and ramirez
gets picked off second base and that
ends the inning well that's all you have
to do the old
three four
to six
harold ramirez bails out the bucks
and the inning comes to an end a man
left for cleveland perez walked his
first time up
the 1-1 swung on ground ball to first
bobbled by bradley as he picks it up now
he recovers takes it to the bag in time
for the out side retired
pirates threatened but do not score four
complete in pittsburgh
it's the tribe two pittsburgh nothing
to a board with two away
bobby bradley the lefty
shreve trying to strand the two runners
he's just inherited the pitch swinging a
soft ground ball
onto the shortstop newman he flings it
onto first for the out and the inning
ends
one hit two left for cleveland will go
to the bottom of the fifth it's two
nothing cleveland
and not allowing a run
to brian hayes
has grounded out and walked
here's the o2
swung on there's a chopper to third
charging chang gloves throws got him at
first
really good inning for cuatro low
pitches
sets them down in order three up three
down we head to the sixth
michael perez is coming up he's getting
some thump
one mistake the pirates could have the
lead
and a fly ball to right field going back
is ramirez to the wall and clear the
deck with a cannonball
michael perez
with one swing has given the pirates the
lead
a three-run blast
number five and the pirates now lead it
brian reynolds coming up
oh one on reynolds
and a fly ball to right field clear the
deck cannonball coming
anchor down
b ray number 12.
a blast
he's on fire
so are the bucks all of a sudden lead at
six to
two oh go get it do what you got to do
number 12 for reynolds
kevin newman will be the batter
the 2-1
swung and grounded up the middle to his
left the shortstop rosario flips it to
the second baseman hernandez for the
inning ending force
what an inning if you're a pirates fan
two home runs one of the allegheny river
pirates six indians two seven in the
books harold ramirez one for three a
solo homer to left way back in the
second inning
the pitch a swing by ramirez he hammers
one high deep to left center it is gone
and harold ramirez has a two-homer game
that's his fifth home run of the year
and a multi-homer game for harold
ramirez
and the indians
are trailing it 6-3 in the ninth
and rodriguez
trying to get through rene rivera who
homered earlier today
raise the jolly roger again
this time it's the pirates who come back